you should have gone for the head hey
everybody its charlie huge news Netflix
and Marvel just cancelled daredevil
season 3 I don't feel so good mr.
Netflix there is no coincidence that
they just cancelled iron fist Luke Cage
and daredevil after some of their best
seasons so far we'll do a new round of
that IMAX ticket giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your favorite daredevil memory on
the video obviously there's a lot of bad
news but there is some good news in all
this so I just broke this down top-10
style Netflix is official statement here
Marvel's daredevil will not return for a
fourth season on Netflix we are
tremendously proud of this shows last
and final season and although it's
painful for the fans we feel it best to
close this chapter on a high note we're
thankful to our partners at Marvel
showrunner Erik Olson the show's writers
stellar crew and incredible cast
including Charlie Cox as daredevil
himself and were grateful to the fans
who have supported the show over the
years while the series on Netflix has
ended the three existing seasons will
remain on the service for years to come
meaning that Netflix is going to keep
all of the episodes and all that content
that they've made with those characters
but number 9 they go on to say this is
the really good part
while the daredevil character will live
on in future projects for Marvel so
Netflix themselves is saying that Marvel
is intending on using the daredevil
character in future projects like on the
disney streaming service which I'll talk
about in a second eight you'll remember
they said the exact same thing about the
Iron Fist character in the Luke Cage
character there's still a couple shows
they haven't terminated yet but Marvel
sounds like it has plans for these
characters so not just daredevil even
though they were pretty explicit like oh
yeah Marvel is definitely going to be
using this character in a brand new
project coming soon but 7 what are those
future projects early prediction is that
they'll most likely be some of those
Avengers 4 spin-off TV series they've
greenlit for the new Disney Plus
streaming service launching late in 2019
we don't have an exact launch date for
that service but based on the schedule
with which Marvel announced the new
series that they've already greenlit it
sound
the Loki Thor series will be the first
one to premiere maybe between October
and November of next year it'd be weird
for them to launch a series in December
usually big live-action shows launch in
the fall sometime between October and
November what I'm expecting is is that
Disney is gonna release an official
schedule for the Disney Plus streaming
service of all their shows not just the
marble shows but everything at d23 next
year which is happening the month after
comic-con so just to be clear d23 is
happening right before they launch that
service so 6:00 this goes hand-in-hand
with what Marvel is doing next summer
Marvel sat out comic-con because they
were in-between Avengers films and it
was such a downer ending after infinity
wars they weren't ready to start
celebrating Avengers 4 yet because you
can't really explain why they'd come
back without giving away spoilers and
because next year that won't be a big
problem they can come back to comic-con
they'll have already completed the Fox
Disney deal so they're Marvel panel next
year is gonna be huge
they can release their phase 4 movies
scheduled start hyping Black Widow in
the Eternals movie which would be some
of the first movies they release and
phase 4 besides spider-man far from home
and they can reveal what their first
x-men or Fantastic Four fox based Marvel
movie is going to be now that they're
back in the MCU because if you haven't
heard the news
Marvel is expecting that deal to finish
by the time Avengers 4 is hitting
theaters in early May so I think they'll
spend most of comic-con just talking
about MCU Marvel stuff and then they'll
save all the TV stuff for the Disney
streaming service 4d 23 which is the
month after comic-con got to get real
though number 5 the fact that Netflix
has canceled three of the five Marvel
series means that cancellations aren't
as much about the quality of the past
seasons of the shows but part of a
larger business move and shift away from
the Disney Marvel licensed content
several times over the last year the
Disney CEO has revealed that they're
pulling all Disney content of any kind
from Netflix over the course of next
year as the contract start to expire
there's some stuff that'll price down a
little bit longer because they signed
contracts a little more recently but all
that stuff is coming to the Disney Plus
streaming service except for the Marvel
Netflix shows they were kind of hanging
in the balance because Netflix paid to
make those and they have the rights to
those episodes but not necessarily to
the characters
which is why Netflix is saying that the
characters will live on in other
projects but they're saying that the
episodes will always remain exclusive to
Netflix which number four I think gives
you an idea for what Marvel's real plans
are for these characters so obviously we
don't get daredevil season four we don't
get Luke Cage season four I think the
fact that Netflix is keeping all the old
episodes of that stuff exclusive to
Netflix means that Marvel isn't just
gonna turn around and do say daredevil
season 4 on the Disney Plus streaming
service they'll just put daredevil in
some other TV show in the same thing
with Luke Cage Jessica Jones and
probably The Punisher so if you're
hoping for daredevil season 4 it just
seems like they're not gonna do that
now maybe if they had gotten rights to
all the episodes like if they could get
all three seasons on that Disney Plus
streaming service then they might do
daredevil season 4 but it would be
really weird for fans who are brand new
to the series to see seasons on
different services like oh if you want
to watch season 1 you got to buy this
other streaming service but if you want
to see the new season you have to
subscribe to this other streaming
service so I don't think the Disney
wants to bifurcate its audience that way
so just more evidence that they'll
appear in somebody else's TV series 3
kingpin Vincent D'Onofrio himself has
said for years he would love to do a
spider-man project with Tom Hollands
Peter Parker this is a clip of him
talking about that a little while ago
can I see spider-man now fans would kill
me if I didn't say Spidey huh what
Spidey would be really nice to drop by
daredevil of course kingpin wants to do
something with spider-man right now
because of what happened Netflix
canceling the series it's a lot easier
for Marvel to use that character
wherever they want they can put him in a
Sony spider-man film if they want to
there's no weird usage clause a la
Netflix Sony competing businesses
because technically they originated that
character in the Marvel Netflix series
so I think if they actually wanted to
use him in a spider-man movie they would
have to get Netflix to sign off on that
and Simon some sort of Co licensing
arrangement but now that that's all done
there are no issues with that they can
put Vincent D'Onofrio kingpin anywhere
they want in the MCU no big deal - based
on the shows the Disney has already
announced Loki Scarlet Witch envisioned
team-up and then the Winter Soldier
Falcon team-up series my best guess
is that the show that they add daredevil
to has not been announced yet he doesn't
really work as a character with Scarlet
Witch envisioned just because they're
basically gods within the MCU they're so
powerful and even though Winter Soldier
and Falcon are pretty grounded
characters they're Secret Avengers
traveling all over the world jet-setting
style and daredevil still feels very
much like a character localized to New
York City so don't be surprised if
sometime next summer Marvel announces
other news shows that they're developing
for the streaming service with MCU
characters the daredevil appears on they
haven't said anything about doing a
Marvel Defender Series but it's always
possible that they could bring all the
characters back but right now it sounds
like they might scatter them around just
a little bit like when they come back
they might not all come back at the same
time so number one the obvious I feel
like we got to talk about Punisher
season two and Jessica Jones season
three have already finished shooting
their new episodes Netflix confirmed
that they're gonna air those episodes
they didn't say exactly when but
sometime early next year but because of
this recent daredevil cancellation I
think that all the nails are in all the
coffins for all these shows so a month
after Punisher season two premieres in a
month after Jessica Jones season 3
premieres you'll probably hear the same
story from Netflix and Marvel like we
just decided to part ways we're really
happy with what we did but we're gonna
take these characters and do something
else with them post all your reactions
in the comments below and let me know
which New Avengers spin-off MCU TV show
do you want daredevil to pop up on
there's a bunch of Captain Marvel news
we actually just found out who Jude Law
is playing for real so I might do a
video for that sometime in the next day
or two leave your requests in the
comments below click here for my
breakdown of all those cool details the
Russos gave about Avengers for an
infinity war at that special event and
click here from a new Avengers 4 teaser
trailer video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight